I came home from vacation recently jet
lagged tired after delayed flights and a
lost bag with my cranky preschooler and
my husband trudging behind me and I
forgot the code to my front
door we've lived in this house for seven
years I'd put the code in the door
hundreds of times before and as I stood
there staring at the keypad I thought oh
boy I'm finally losing my
mind our brains have an incredible
capacity to store memory but not all of
that information is accessible at
once an article in scientific America
estimates the human brain can store 2.5
million gigabytes of data that's about
5,000 iPhones but if you've ever
forgotten a password before you know
that memory is not always easy to access
because memory is not just one
system those different systems have
limits and a number of factors in our
daily lives can impact our memory
efficiency there was a famous
neuropsychology case study of a patient
referred to as patient hm who became
like a real life 10-second Tom after
brain surgery to treat a seizure
disorder in terms of his seizures the
surgery was a success they were less
severe and less
frequent but after his surgery hm became
unable to consciously learn new things
for example he worked with the same
neuropsychologist for years he never
remembered meeting her he'd introduce
himself each time and he never
remembered doing the different tasks
that she would bring to test his memory
but here's the interesting
part his performance got better on some
of those tasks over
time he never remembered doing them he
always thought he was doing them for the
first time
but his brain had learned the procedures
without him being aware we learned from
patient hm and others like him that
there are different types of
memory some memories come to mind almost
automatically like if you're walking
through a garden and you smell the
flowers that your grandma used to keep
on her kitchen table and all of a sudden
you're thinking of your favorite memory
with your
grandma but other memories take more
brain power and effort to recall like
trying to remember my new computer
password
because some memories take more brain
power and effort to recall they're also
more prone to
interference you're at the grocery store
and you're trying to remember 10 things
that you need to pick up but you're run
into your neighbor in the produce
section and after a few minutes of
chitchat hearing about their new car you
can only remember two of those 10
things even though our memory storage is
pretty impressive 5,000 iPhones big the
the short-term memory that you're using
to keep track of your grocery list is
more like seven plus or minus two bits
of information and it's really easy to
throw that active short-term memory off
track the problem we live in a very
distracting modern world you're at a
meeting at work and you're trying to
remember all the details of a project
that you're working on so that you can
share it with your team but at the same
time your brain is paying attention to
what your colleagues are saying trying
to ignore all the email alerts popping
up on your computer distracted by text
messages from your family asking what's
for dinner and wondering if they're
going to take a break soon because you
could really use some more
coffee ignoring all those distractions
and competing priorities takes up a lot
of
energy when our brains are juggling 400
things we're more likely to make a
memory error like forgetting a
colleague's name in a meeting or missing
a key part of your presentation and then
beating yourself up for the rest of the
day for making that mistake which brings
us to another brain draining habit that
can mess up your memory and make it hard
to remember where you left your keys
stress doesn't have to be huge or major
stressors either all those day-to-day
stresses pressures and deadlines take up
brain space too and force our brain to
do a bunch of mental
multitasking last summer I locked myself
in a stairwell twice in the same week
because I was trying to do this mental
multitasking I was packing up at the end
of the day and at the same time I was
thinking about phone calls I needed to
make tomorrow and ideas for a project
that I was working on and what I was
going to make for supper that night and
whether I should pick up my daughter
before or after I get groceries and I
left my keys in my office twice in the
same week apparently door locks aren't
my thing an article from Queens
University estimates we have 6 200
thoughts each day that's a lot of
potential for
distractions there was a study at the
University of California that found when
we're interrupted like with distractions
or multitasking we try to compensate by
working faster but this makes us feel
more stressed and as you can imagine
it's not very
efficient we've all been in situations
where we feel a bit stressed out and
overwhelmed by our never ending to-do
lists between emails and phone calls and
zoom meetings and project deadlines
we're coming home from work feeling
tired and our brains are burnt
out there was an article published in
the journal science of learning that
showed stress not only impacts our
memory retrieval so it's hard to
remember that door code when you need it
stress also makes it hard for our brains
to problem solve and think of Creative
Solutions like how I'm going to get into
my house when I can't remember my door
code we know all those day-to-day
stresses pressures and deadlines can
mess up our memory but what about bigger
stresses like the uncertainty and change
of living through a multi-year pandemic
Financial pressure family stress these
stresses drain brain resources too
making us more likely to make mistakes
and making it harder to remember the
things we need to
remember so memory errors are normal
especially when you're tired overworked
or stressed out that's great to know but
I still need to get into my house at the
end of my
vacation how do we boost our memory in
these situations and recharge those
brain cells it's tempting to try and
just think harder but that doesn't
always work have you ever been trying to
think of the name of a movie or an actor
and it's right on the tip of your tongue
but you can't quite remember it and then
four hours later you're driving home
from work and that name comes to you out
of the blue yeah me too totally
normal when it comes to our memory
thinking harder doesn't always work
because of a process of competitive
inhibition of the neurons in your
brain basically when you try to think
too hard about one super specific piece
of memory like a name or a code the
brain cells in that part of your brain
get overloaded and blocked they need
time to
recharge that's why 4 hours later that
memory comes back you still there still
in your memory storage just the access
route has been exhausted and needs time
to reset plus remember how stress makes
our brains less efficient when we're
worried about making mistakes we're more
likely to make more mistakes do this
instead if you're feeling more forgetful
than usual or your brain feels stuck and
you can't seem to find the memory you
need it might be a sign that your brain
needs a
reset can't remember a code or a
password standing at your door like me
and you can think of every four-digit
code you know except the one you need
think about something else for a few
minutes anything else chat with the
store clerk at the grocery store about
the weather instead of staring at the
debit machine trying to remember your
bank code or pull out your phone and
scroll social media for a few
minutes this works because instead of
exhausting the brain cells you need to
find that memory you activate other
parts of your brain giving those memory
centers a chance to recharge and
reset making more mistakes than normal
at work you can't seem to send an email
without a typo or you're stumbling over
your words in a meeting get up and take
a real break go for a walk around your
office or do something fun for a few
minutes these micro breaks refresh your
mental resources and give your brain
back the energy and focus it needs to
find that
information memory error aren't a sign
or losing your mind they might be a sign
your brain needs a little break and a
reset thank you